I have a really interesting clip from
The Joe Rogan program Matt Walsh has
become an expert to the right wing about
gender and trans issues
he did a documentary about trans issues
he confronts people about
um gender affirming care and all these
different things and it turns out that
he's just a liar he's just a liar and
there was a very interesting moment
wherein yesterday on Joe Rogan's podcast
Matt Walsh was saying millions of trans
people are on puberty blockers hundreds
of thousands are getting hundreds of
thousands of miners prepubescent girls
are getting gender reassignment surgery
and it's all untrue let's start with the
clip it's fact checked by Joe Rogan's
producer Jamie during the the interview
and everything this is a clinic this is
a clinic in critical thinking let's
listen how many people have had this
done
depends on what I don't think we have
exact numbers but it's if we do have
exact we do have numbers we have very
good numbers on what's happening in the
United States there are there are you
can there is data for how many
procedures of just about every kind are
being done we're talking about the drugs
it's I mean Millions okay so Millions on
puberty blockers all right let's
continue
do you talk about hormone blockers yeah
but millions of kids have been on
hormone blockers really uh
I'm sure someone's going to fact check
me on me but my my guess is that we're
in we're into the millions now at this
point yeah that'll be my guess
um uh I I can say
for double mastectomies the most Okay so
Millions on hormone blockers my millions
of minors on hormone blockers the best
data I was able to find is that there's
a hundred and twenty thousand
children
struggling with what is often called
gender dysphoria
some small fraction of those at some
point might take some of these
medications okay he says Millions a year
the total number with gender dysphoria
120 000 only a fraction of those are
taking these medications so first lie do
the numbers really even matter to these
people I don't think so but there's the
first lie I read a report recently that
there were over a thousand but let me
back up because now they're on to
something else uh I I can say
for double mastectomies the most I've
read a report recently that
um there were over a thousand done
between 2016 and 2019 and when you
compare that to how many were done
between you know 2008 and 2015 it's just
it's a massive okay but that's 300 a
year
huh that doesn't sound so high does it
but that's not even really right let's
continue increase and uh over a thousand
girls that double most gender affirming
double mastectomies in that in that time
frame else you're talking about
prepubescent right minors oh now did you
see what just happened there
you're talking about prepubescent
double mastectomies for prepubescent
girls we'll get back to that that
doesn't make sense either and he goes
That's Right minors okay
prepubescent and minor are two different
things
I'm sure you know that but did you see
how slickly he slipped that in I'll play
it once more and uh over a thousand
girls that double gender affirming
double mastectomies in that in that time
frame girls you're talking about
prepubescent right minors right minors
so two different things now of course
you might say do prepubescent girls have
breasts could can you even do a double
mastectomy on a prepubescent girl what
exactly are you removing and of course
if you research this it you you start to
find medical information about it it is
very rare that prepubescent girls
actually have breasts and you can read
about what happens to the nipple and
okay you're right I mean we don't need
to go into detail about everything but
at face value this doesn't make sense
prepubescent girls who almost never have
breasts are having their breasts removed
that's really weird but then he slips in
right these are minors so you could
actually be talking about a 17 and a
half year old girl
not prepubescent legally a minor
completely different situation doesn't
make anything right or wrong
but it's a completely different
situation than what he claims uh and
that's just up until 2019 and then we
know that uh there's been this
exponential increase with all this stuff
year over year so
um it's it's a lot it's too many you
know one having this happen to one kid
says who it's a lot more than one yeah
look if you're an adult and you want to
do that and you understand who you are
and what you are and this is how you
feel you should progress you're an adult
this is a free country you should be
able to do whatever you want but when
you're talking about doing that to
Children the fact that so many people
are on board and so many people are
angry if you have like people are going
to be angry at us that we're having
these conversations now uh how could you
be angry that they're having the
conversation the problem is that Walsh
just lies
yeah they will be and I also
I actually think that uh that that this
should this shouldn't be happening to so
now they've pulled up an article
it's a very small number if that's right
it says over the last five years there
were at least 4 780 adolescents who
started puberty blockers okay
he said there are millions of
adolescents on puberty blockers they
just found a study that says it's under
five thousand
over five years that's under a thousand
a year he said millions
study says it's under a thousand think
about that and at a prior gender
dysphoria diagnosis under a thousand a
year he said millions it's kind of under
counted but that's
that would be a big 100
000 people a year yeah
hmm yeah I mean I I would guess you know
hundreds of thousands
let me correct my wrong guess of
millions because you found that the real
number is 900 and say it's probably
hundreds of thousands I can't now get
away with saying it's Millions because
the data says it's 900. so let's just go
with hundreds of thousands because but I
could be wrong you are wrong million
sounds great
right it sounds it's much better for the
story
so listen guys
um there are about nine thousand the re
everything I found from medical journals
reporting on this there are about 9 000
trans surgeries performed annually
across the United States total and
that's all ages what's called male to
female and female to male that's any
type okay
that's mostly adults okay and
um what fraction of those are the
situation that Matt Walsh is talking
about I mean almost none now then they
always the problem with these people is
then you'll they'll they'll revert back
to even one is too many that's different
the first case they make is this is an
epidemic this is a fad everybody's doing
it you just show up and they cut off
your breasts even if you don't have any
if you're an 11 year old girl you've got
no breasts they'll cut them off what are
they cutting off Matt I don't know
they're doing it
millions of people on people you know
all this stuff then you give them the
real numbers they go well one is too
many oh but that's a different argument
now your first argument was it's too
widely available
it's absolutely horrifying and good for
Jamie for at least interjecting and
injecting some data into this before you
go if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more please make sure to subscribe
to my YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
Pacman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description